どうもみなさんこんにちははじめ社長です
夏といえば
虫そう今日私はですねこちら
高山市民の森っていうところに来ており
ます
麺がそのカブトムシが取れるスポットって
結構全国的にあるんですけども
めちゃくちゃうるせえな日暮らしの中頃に
カブトムシが取れるスポットって全国的に
なるんですけどもここですね
静岡でも
めちゃくちゃカブトムシが取れる
らしいということで今回行きましたもうね
夕方だねそろそろ日が暮れてかうるせーな
セミの量がすごいもうこれが全て物語っ
てる多分虫の量がかなりすごいんです
けれども今日はそんなですねカブトムシが
たくさん取れると言われている山に
カブトムシを捕まえに来ました見れば
わかりますこれ最近買ったんよ
カブトムこれそうだね基本でも何でもいけ
ますねそこそこ高い所にいてもですねこれ
があればもう全然届くというですねすごい
こういうとこにいても使われますこうやっ
てこれやばくない
Tシャツも
伝わってますよ
ちょっと
夏ということでやっぱ捕まえたいじゃん
カブトムシというわけでこの大量に
カブトムシが取れると言われている
スポットに今日めちゃくちゃいろんな
トラップとか仕掛け準備してきました1番
の今回の武器はですねついに持ってき
ちゃいましたよ
[拍手]
こちら
10万ルーメラン
持ってきましたいやこれは強いでしょこの
大きさカブトムシというか虫だね昆虫の
習性としてカブトムシ光があるところに
集まるのでこれでドカン照らしとけばもう
全員来ますよカブトムシこの森中のね今日
はねもう10002000から1万匹
ぐらいを
捕まえたいと思ってますすごいよこれ今来
てますよ
捕まえていきたいと思います見て奥まで
全部わかんないよこれ
これだけじゃなくて例えばこの先に白い布
とか置いたら
反射して2倍よねそこにカブトムシがどん
だけ集まるか今日はやっていきたいと思い
ます
[音楽]
はいというわけで
森に着きましたご覧ください
[音楽]
今車のライトで焚いてるんですけれども
結構深い森ですもうひとっけ全くなし
やっぱりね真のカブトムシスポットっての
はきっとこういう場所なんですよもうね
すっごいここまで来るとなかなかいないん
だろうなっていう場所まで来ましたでね
ここマジでカブトムシで取れるんだろう
なっていうのがありましてご覧ください
昆虫再生の
参考資料クヌギ抜きっていうカブトムシが
好きな気があるんですけども目印でピンク
色のビニールテープついてるらしいんです
よなぜすごいかつカブトムシが好きな気が
あるとそしてこっちご覧ください
緑色がクヌギの木これある場所が
カブトムシが好きな場所です全部書いて
ありますマジで狙うのであれば密集してる
となるとここか
ここら辺かなっていう気はしますちょっと
歩いてみましょうかはいというわけで
こんなわかりやすいところないですよ
カブトムシが好きな木の位置全部書いて
るっていうピンクのシールを貼って
るっていう事でちょっととりあえず罠
仕掛けるスポットだけ決めたいと思います
行ってきますでは探していきましょうどう
するかな
もうこれとかそうなんだろうね見てピンク
色のシール貼ってあるんですよこれは多分
カブトムシが好きな木だと思いますピンク
のシール貼ってるのマジありがたいね
ピンクのシールが密集しているところとか
に罠を仕掛けたいっていうのが今回の狙い
ですね
[音楽]
俺たちはどこにいるんだすげぇ気が多いね
なんかちゃんと捕まえに来たことあんまり
ないからな去年マックスのお姉さんの山で
先生の車にトラップ仕掛けて置いてみたん
ですけども1匹も来なかっていう今回は
シーズンがカブトムシがちょうど超盛んな
時期に来てるんでかなり期待できる
あこれとかは
ほら見て
透明なビニールにピンク色にスプレー
かかってんだけどこれフェイクか
遊び心ある山だねちょっと神殿に探します
[拍手]
今頭の部分通ったね
カブトムシかでも
濃いハートだった
皆さん見つけましたご覧くださいクヌギの
木発見しましたこれがクヌギの木か細いの
ね結構でこっちもこれもじゃあクヌギぽい
よねクヌギだこれもきっとこれ狙いつける
の大事だろうねどこかによって全然変わり
そうカブトムシ捕まるかどうかクヌギの木
というより多分樹液が出てるやつがいいん
だろうな
[拍手]
えお墓何ここ
カブトムシって書いてあります
打ちすぎでしょこれ誰か多分捕まんなくて
怒りでここで十分ぶっ放したんで
カブトムシって
結局で大丈夫
1回下のところ待って待って待って見て見
て
なんか
ぽかったけどね
めっちゃでかくなかったよ
めっちゃマジで話ししてる時に出てき
ちゃったけどこれいるよ
マジきついんだよねもうちょっと距離とっ
てくれればねいいんだけどあえて開いたら
人の横通ろうとするから
煽り運転みたいな感じだよね
したらこれ見てきていい何の木だ
変えて知らねーなカエデって書いてあった
楓おば様って覚えてる
犬夜叉の
桔梗の妹だったかな
俺の推しキャラだよ
俺が腕振れば全部光るぜ
腕が持つ限り頑張るぜ
疲れたぜあこれかちょっと待って
これデカすぎんじゃない
こんなとこに役すぎがありましたすげーよ
実物を見るの初めてだただいないいない
けどこんだけ太いとちょっとねいいね
これ桜関連してくれよちょっと木が多すぎ
て難しいねこれは
水菜どっち
ちょっと見てきますね
失礼します
いやいや
勾配が
急だな
見るね
なんか突進してきた
圭介
なんかいる見せるねこれでもあのごめん
多分カブトムシではない
けど
めっちゃいかついのいるこれ誰俺の記憶が
正しいのは多分髪切り虫とかな類かな触覚
ガチ長いけど
先客いるって結構さ大手になるよねいいっ
てことですねでも樹液出てないじゃない
ですか
大丈夫ちゃんとトラップ
準備してきましたこちらご覧ください
どうぞ僕です
トラップ作っていきたいと思います
材料はバナナカルピス焼酎両方準備しまし
たバナナを切っていきます
[音楽]
なんか痛そうですね
ちょっと男性からするとショッピングの
映像かもしれません
申し訳ございません綺麗なバナナより
傷んで濡れてるバナナの方がカブトムシは
集まると言われていますなので何なので
もっと炒め付けたいぐらい
次にカルピスを入れますひたひたにする
ぐらいがいいんでしょうねどんどん入れて
いきましょう
バナナにカルピスってこれはもう
見ても立ってもいられないんじゃないか
カブトムシはこれでも完成なんですけれど
もさらにここに焼酎を入れていきますカブ
同士は樹液に集まると言われているんです
けどもこのバナナとカルピスまたはバナナ
とショーツの組み合わせがすごく
樹液と似てるらしいです
[音楽]
OKこんなもんかなこれで完成ですという
わけでトラップそしてそれに追加で市販の
昆虫採集用のジェルみたいなやつも買って
きたので
樹液はこっちで出します彼らにはもうそこ
にくっついてきてほしいで色々見回ったん
ですけども多分この木が一番いいかなと
思います
これどうでしょう結構高いのよそして
すごいよねでかいなこの木で行こうかなと
思いますはいというわけで早速トラップ
仕掛けていきたいと思います
もっとすごいところ見つけたぞマジです
うわぁ全く同意
[音楽]
まず多分ほらピンクなるでしょうこれが
全部そうで
奥すごいこれは
[音楽]
太いぞどうこれ
最高です
めっちゃ太いよねこの木とこの木でここら
辺でちょっとトラップ仕掛けたいと思い
ますというわけでこのでかい木とこの木に
トラップ仕掛けていくわけなんですけれど
もまずですねカブトムシ明るいところに
行きます明るい場所に虫が来るのでライト
を当てて反射するような白い布を準備し
ますタオルケットタオル準備しました
なんかね布団のシーツとかでもいいんです
けども
虫がツルツル滑っちゃって触れないと思っ
てこういうタオルにしてみましたこれを
貼っていくぜいやーこんだけでかいと
すごいでしょ
[音楽]
この白さよこの広さこんだけ広い布に世界
一明るいライトぶち当てれば光まぶしすぎ
て絶対カブトムシきますセットしていき
ましょうイメージはもうこういう感じです
ここに世界一明るいとブチ当てると虫は
高いところにいるのでなるべく高いところ
に
鶴島
絶対落ちないね
耐えれますはいというわけで完成しました
ここに世界一明るいライトぶち当てだと
思うんですけどもその前にトラップも
仕掛けたいと思います
トラップですこれがねもうカブトムシ大
好物ほぼ樹液と同じような感じらしいので
仕掛けていきたいと思いますストッキング
開けます
[音楽]
よしストッキングたくさん出ましたこの
ストッキングの中に最強のトラップを入れ
ていきますそうするとストッキングから
このエキスがにじみ出てそれにつられて
カブトムシが近寄ってくっつい誰
コガネムシだすごい効果だな
もうよじ登ろうとしてるもんあなたそんな
飲みたいのねこれ入れていきます
ストッキングの中に見分けのストッキング
すごい匂いするマジで
おいしい
あなたは昆虫入れるよ
[音楽]
ね
きっとどんどん作っていきましょう
[音楽]
その道の動きだよねどういい感じです
めちゃめちゃいっぱい撮りたいですね今日
はもう今日だけはね取れなかったみたいな
おっちゃんマジで許せねえこれどう
いい感じです長すぎ結構もう来てるのでで
ストッキングかけれる場所がそんなに
なかったのでちょっとこれで行かせて
くださいこれも開けて近くに放置しとき
ますどう
めっちゃ来るねこれ
匂いこうやって
充満させてみんな集まりますっていう作品
ですこれも準備しましたペイントゼリー
これ餌にもなるんですけど
昆虫最初に育てるだけじゃなくて野外の
昆虫採集にも使えるらしいのでこれ
ちょっと手に塗って仕掛けておきたいと
思いますうっすら
染み込ませときたいよね
こういうとこにね
[音楽]
勘違いして集まるんじゃないか説がある
めっちゃ来そうそれはいというわけで
仕掛けトラップは完成したのでこの白い
ところに
世界一明るいライト1回ぶち当ててみたい
と思いますここで太陽できちゃうよ
太陽神ラーの降臨だ
来ましたよ皆さん行くよ
やばいちょっと待ってやばいどうなるどう
なってるえお昼こここれすごいなこれ
太陽だね
待ってマックスじゃなかった
これがマックスだ見てだって
全部見えてない見てこの
奥も全部見えますもうこれがこれが世界
ライトだもう音でわかると思うんですけど
も結構フルパワーで稼働してましてそんな
に長い時間つけることができないんです
けどちょっと可能な限りつけてカブトムシ
が集まるかどうか見てみたいと思いますで
は
まだいないですけども結構ね色んな虫が
くっついてきてます
がなんかすごいハートが聞こえたけどうわ
怖い
早めに退散しますもう虫がどんどん集まっ
てきてもパラダイスになってるんで最強の
ライトを炊いておきますねいつ消えるかも
わかんないのでちょっと怖いんですけど力
の限り頑張ってもらいたいと思いますいき
ますね
[音楽]
また朝に会いましょう帰ろう
ただいま朝の4時ですおはようございます
明日前のこの時間がちょっとたくさんいる
んじゃないかなと思いますちょっと見に
行ってみましょう
[音楽]
いないかなぁそうな感じあるね
他にないかなちょっと近くまで見てみます
[音楽]
ありがたい発生してる
許せないです
朝です皆さんちょっと朝まで最強ライト
耐えてもうちょっと様子見てみましょう
[音楽]
朝です朝というかまだ4時半ぐらいなん
ですけれどももう日が結構登り始めている
のでそろそろ
終了でいいかなと思います果たして
カブトムシはいるのかいないのかどっちな
んだい見ていきたいと思います
[音楽]
何も言いませんでしたちょっと待って
くださいよなんかね虫はめっちゃいるん
ですよ
めちゃめちゃいるんですけど
肝心のカブトムシがいないですねこれ超虫
だらけだけどちょっといないよなぁ
あれ
増加部と
夕方からずっとやってさ何も捕まらなかっ
た
と思うじゃないですか2時にこんなことが
ありましたVTRどうぞはいどうも2時
です
朝まで待ってるともったいないので来まし
た
ちょっとだけ見に行きましょうね
[音楽]
さすがにいてほしいけどな予想言っていい
ですか
[音楽]
すげークワガタ
ミヤマクワガタかなミヤマクワガタ1匹
捕まりましたおめでとうございます
カブトムシ
捕まえに来てクワガタを見つけるという
ことでした
0よりかは良かったね結構大きかった気が
するんですけれどなんでなんだろう
シーズン的にはもう間違いなくもう今なの
よ虫選んだ木が悪かったのか
餌トラップが悪かったのかちょっと
何かしらの要因があると思うんですけれど
も
ゼロでした
というわけでなんか場所とかシーズンとか
色々
噛み合ってなくて出なかったんでもう1
か所ちょっと仕掛けさせてください全く
同じ仕掛け準備しました今夕方なんです
けどもここに仕掛けて深夜また来て世界一
明るいライトをぶっさせばきっと集まるん
じゃないかと思いますで今回なんです
けれどもまたカブトムシ0匹だったら僕
マジで多分動画3年半休むんで同じ失敗を
したくなくて
弟
虫好きなので1回ここでテストしてます
カブトムシ言いましたカブトムシ言いまし
たよね
ここですでは仕掛けていきましょうまた
深夜にお会いしましょうはい深夜になり
ました
罠を仕掛けで結構時間が経ちました
ちょっと見に行きましょう
いやいやでやっぱ香料が足りないよ
激しい匂いを放っています
[音楽]
0持ってきました世界一明るいライト早速
ぶっ放したいと思いますよし
あります
[音楽]
さあこれで大量に虫が集まってくるはず
もう少し待ってみましょう
ちょっと充電が持つ限り置いときたいと
思います
では
はいというわけで3時半になりましたもう
ちょっとしたら多分日が上がってくると
思うんですけれども果たしてどうなってる
んでしょうか見ていきましょう
[音楽]
前回きつかったですか
普通にもうやらないって思った
[音楽]
ちょっと待って待って見て見て見て見て
めっちゃいるやんこれ
が本来の姿ですすごくない
ほら見て
いきますすげえでこっちメス2匹女の子
同士でディズニー来ちゃったみたいな感じ
かなこれ来ちゃったから
登ってるねこれこの匂いが強いんかな
すごい何が良かったんだろう
捕まえていくまずはこの女性から行かせて
いただきます
紳士だね
結構なんか力強い強い
はいまずはメスもう一人のね一緒に
ディズニー来ちゃった子も捕まえちゃい
ますよダブルゲット
はオスです
痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い
痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い
[音楽]
痛い今この俺傷口に
爪ここ入れてた
潰しましょう
答えによって全然色が違うほんとだすごい
茶色いなあと何匹だ3匹これがするのか俺
が持つかどうかな
[音楽]
こんにちはって言ってますけど
いやすごいよ見て
爽快よ
[音楽]
すげーこんな捕まったのはいというわけで
6匹オスが4匹とメスが2匹ですねいや
元気だなぁこれが果たしてこのライトの力
なのかエサの力なのかちょっとこの布の力
なのかわかんないんですけれども
こんなもんよねこいつらを
持ち帰りたいと言いたいところなんです
けどもすいません僕ヘラクレス
専門ですちょっと日本のカブトムシも育て
たいと思ってるんですけどちょっと今
ヘラクレスに愛情を注ぎたいのでこの子達
は見つからないでリリースしたいと思い
ますこれやっぱ世界一明るいライトのパ
ワーってない
全てが噛み合ったのかもしれないですね
何別の生き物
結構でかいけど
これなんですか
色々いたんですけども2回行ってカブトも
クワガタも捕まったので世界一明るい
ライトは最強です
[音楽]